-Our first guest tonight is
talented actor and musicia
who was recently nominated for
a Best Metal Performance Gramm
with his band Body Count.
He also stars in the
22nd season of
"Law & Order: Special Victim's
Unit,"
which airs Thursdays at 9:00
P.M. here on NBC.
Let's take a look.
-First, Nora's not even sure
that she's gonna go
to the hearing,
but now on the day of she'
willing to go to the priso
and meet with Jimmy?
-She read the letters.
She said she spent the las
seven years of her life
hating the guy.
Maybe it's time to let that go
-He's just going
to manipulate her.
-What am I supposed to do,
tell Nora no?
Why don't you go with her?
-Because I can't.
I got to babysit Kat
at a controlled meet.
Hey, you got any tips
on how to deal with her?
Because everything I do
makes her angry.
-Then don't do anything.
-Please welcome
back to the show, Ice-T.
How are you, Ice?
-What's up, Seth?
What's happening, man?
This is different.
-This is a different thing
we're going through,
but one thing that remains
the same is there keep
being new seasons of "SVU.
You were here two years ag
and talked about the fact
that you were
just a couple of seasons awa
from setting the record.
And now in season 22,
you guys are
the longest-running drama
in the history of television
Congratulations.
-I remember
when we were on like season 18
I was at dinner with Dick Wolf
and he said
we could get the record,
we were getting close
to the record.
And I was like, nah,
we're gonna do 25. Right?
And next thing, you know,
like last season
we got picked up for three
So we officially are going
to get to season 25.
So now I'm pushing season 30
I love doing the show,
and, you know,
if it's not broke, don't fix it.
I'm going to ride this thing
out.
-And I think it's importan
that when you set a record
you've got
to then put some cushion
so that nobody just comes
and takes it right back.
You know,
you got to hold that record.
-It's hard, I mean,
I don't even know the show
that's the closest behind us
but, yeah,
we want to set a cushion.
You know, but, I mean,
fortunately,
I still enjoy doing the show
The fans still love the show
and I'm loving working wit
Mariska every day
and Kelli and Peter
and everybody.
And we've got a new girl, Jamie.
We're having a really good tim
over there.
So people always say, "Ice, ho
could you do the show so long?
I said, "Because the work
environment is so fun."
And then we get guests,
we got stars that come in
every day, so it makes it --
it's an interesting job.
It's not boring at all.
-That's fantastic.
I bet, by the way,
the person you're
going to have to worry about
as far as breaking your record
is going to be Dick Wolf,
because he's going to do it with
one of these other shows.
So I would just keep an ey
on those "Chicago" shows,
'cause I know
they're getting up there.
He's the guy
you got to keep an eye on.
-The trick is you stay
in the Wolf universe.
Like when people say,
"You're on 'SVU,'"
I say, "Really I'm an employee
of Wolf Films."
So when he came out with
"Chicago Fire,"
I made sure I wrote to him
I said, "You know
I can climb a ladder, Dick."
You know, he keeps enough show
on the air
to keep you employed
if he likes you.
He seems to like me.
This is my fifth show I've don
with Dick Wolf, fifth show
I started on "New York
Undercover" as a guest star,
then "Swift Justice,"
I played a gangster.
Then I was in "Law & Order
Exiled," I played a pimp.
They killed me
with a bowling pin.
Then I had -- I played a -
I had a show called "Players,"
and now this is
"Law & Order: SVU."
So I've been working with
Dick Wolf for over 25 years.
I'm probably
one of his longest --
I probably am his longest
continuous running actor
outside of maybe Epatha.
-I think this is important als
that he is teaching people tha
a life of crime doesn't pay,
because when you're a criminal
in the Dick Wolf universe,
you only last one episode.
But you figured out
if you're a cop,
you're just in it
for the long haul.
-I learned that.
I played enough bad guys,
I played enough criminals,
so I know you get one shot
You get to play the bad guy --
unless the show
is based around bad guys,
something like "Breaking Bad
or something like that.
But, you know,
it's fun, it's acting.
People know Ice-T is about a
far as you can get from a cop.
So we call that in the busines
"a stretch."
[ Laughter ]
-How -- A lot of people have
been stretching
through this past year.
I know your beautiful wife
Coco,
is homeschooling your daughter
Chanel.
How has that been going?
-Well, not technically
homeschooling her.
Chanel just turned 5, so she'l
start school in September.
-Gotcha.
-And we didn't really decide t
take her to preschool.
I told her, I don't think
anybody's won
a Nobel Peace Prize
because they went to preschool
I told her, I said, "You hav
the luxury
of being able to be a
stay-at-home mom right now
take advantage of it.
These five years, she'll learn
more just being with you all day
than she probably will getting
shipped out to a preschool."
A lot of kids go to preschoo
because their parents
have to work and it's kind o
like preschool/babysitter.
So Chanel is with us.
I think the hardest thing is
when she starts school is Coco
Coco's going to lose
her best friend
who's with her 24 hours a day.
So Chanel will be like,
"Bye, Mommy."
And Chanel will be the one
crying --
I mean Coco will be the on
crying in the car.
-You did add
some more family members.
We've talked
about your dogs before.
You have two English bulldogs,
Maximus and Alexis.
They had five babies.
We actually have a picture her
of the bulldog puppies.
-Yeah.
-And you kept two, correct
-Yeah, what happened was our
first bulldog was Spartacus,
and what happened was
Spartacus passed away early,
and Spartacus
is Maximus' father.
So we're trying
to keep the bloodline.
We were like, "You know what?"
We work with
Long Island Bulldog Rescue
We know about rescuing dog
and all of that kind of thing,
but with bulldogs, it's like
before you even get ready
to breed them,
somebody wants them.
You know, so it's not
like they're gonna ever
be in that situation.
So Coco was like,
"I want to breed Max.
I want to keep Max."
Max is now 9, the baby.
So we got Alexis,
we bred them, and out came
all of these puppies.
Here's what happened.
One looks just like Spartacus,
like his clone,
and one looks just like Maximus.
So we named Max's son Tita
and the other one's name
is Little Spart.
And Chanel is happy.
And now we have four dogs.
The trick is, you got to -
I mean,
when I get in bed at night
it's like lion country safar
because I've got Chanel
who still sleeps with us.
She climbs into bed.
She's got her own room
and everything,
but she prefers
Mommy and Daddy's bed.
Then we've got -- you know
you have kids, they want to --
you know, you're like, "Look
at how beautiful your room is.
They're like, "Right,
I'll put my toys there."
-[ Laughs ]
-"I'm coming up with you guys.
And then I got the dogs
running around the bed.
So it's --
it's an interesting situation.
-You have, of course,
many projects,
other shows outside of "SVU.
You have a new show
called "The Mediator,"
where you actually mediate
disputes.
What have you learned
from this show that's differen
from everything else
you've done up to this point
-You know what it is, Seth
I started a production company
called Final Level
Entertainment.
And we started putting shows -
I'm learning
from my mentor Dick Wolf
that one show
is not good enough.
So I have a show called
"In Ice Cold Blood" on Oxygen,
one called "Framed by the
Killer" on Oxygen
and then this one came up,
"The Mediator."
So my guys that work on my tea
were like,
"Conflict resolution, Ice,
you're the best person
for that."
I'm like, "I'm not no judge,
dude.
I'm not wearing no robe.
I'm not --"
They said, "No, mediation.
Mediation."
So they caught my ear
and they said,
"Now you have to go to mediation
before you go to court."
Then I realized
that every human being
has mediated something
at some point.
You've done it.
You get between your brother
and your sister.
You get between your friends
Someone wants a neutral person
to get in between it.
So the beauty of the show
is I'm trying to help people
solve problems.
It's nothing
like court because --
well we also have
a lawyer there,
so once they tell me
the problems,
I try to come with a solution.
Then I go to my people,
I call them my chambers.
I have sometimes an attorney
who will tell you
what would happen
if you did take it to court.
I have relationship experts,
psychiatrists.
I've got my man Freddie Fox,
A.K.A. Bumpy Knuckles,
he'll tell you
how it would happen
in his form of,
you know, justice.
It just comes out cool and the
I give a recommendation,
and they either take it
or they leave it.
And we shot 20 episodes,
and it is bananas.
It is so fun, but the trick is
we're not making fun
of the people.
It's not like Jerry Springer
where we're just there
for the clash.
We're really trying
to help solve a problem.
And we're pretty successful.
I mean, it's --
it's interesting.
I didn't know what was going
to happen when we started it
but it turned out to be
something pretty incredible.
-Well, congratulations on that
Congratulations
on everything else.
Good luck at the Grammys,
and hopefully, next time
we'll see you in person.
-I hope so, man. I hope so
Everybody out there dealin
with COVID, God bless you.
You know,
it happened in my family.
We've gone through it, so we
know it's serious business
So, you know, God bless yo
and your loved ones.
-"Law & Order: SVU"
airs Thursdays
at 9:00 P.M. here on NBC.